[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta nueva edición de
enlace cono Sur desde Santiago de Chile
en esta ocasión trataremos el tema de la
deserción y la violencia escolar los
datos son alarmantes 50.000 alumnos
abandonaron el sistema escolar entre
2021 y 2022 lo que representa un 2% de
la matrícula esta cifra supone un 24%
más que los alumnos que abandonaron en
2019 previo a la pandemia según informó
el Ministerio de Educación la cifra es
especialmente considerable si tenemos en
cuenta que entre 2004 y 2021 abandonaron
el sistema escolar 227.000 estudiantes
en todo chile además 1,2 millones de
estudiantes están en riesgo de
inexistencia grave lo que representa un
40% de la matrícula la inexistencia
grave es el predictor de una posible
desvinculación escolar posterior la
mayor parte de los estudiantes que
abandonaron el sistema escolar cursaban
la enseñanza básica un
55%, casi la mitad de ellos lo hicieron
en zonas urbanas en la región
metropolitana chilena seguida de
Valparaíso con un 9,6% se trata de un
problema grave que Debemos enfrentar
todos como desafío país señaló al dar a
conocer las cifras el ministro de
Educación chileno según datos de la
defensoría de la niñez los niños niñas y
adolescentes no escolarizados están más
expuestos a vincularse con situaciones
que infringen la ley o factores de
riesgo como el consumo de drogas la
violencia escolar se ha disparado con
respecto a años anteriores a la pandemia
según datos de la superintendencia de
Educación las denuncias por violencia se
incrementaron más de un 50% con respecto
al año anterior entre ellos colegios
suspendidos por amenazas de muerte
contra profesores y directores armas de
fuego e intentos de suicidio dentro de
las aulas amenazas de masacre escolar en
las instituciones apuñalamientos de una
madre o profesor a plena luz del día en
un establecimiento también de alumnos y
en educación preuniversitaria liceos a
los que se prendió fuego incendios de
buses en la vía pública ataques con
Molotov marchas callejeras de alumnas
denunciando acoso sexual solo el liceos
emblemáticos considerados lugares
preuniversitarios de prestigioso nivel
educativo se registraron más de 397
intervenciones por violencia con más de
100 alumnos detenidos según datos de la
policía para los expertos el prolongado
cierre de los colegios en el país que en
Chile promedió un total de 77 semanas
frente a las 38 de la media mundial es
una de las razones que se encuentra
detrás de este fenómeno los niños y
adolescentes No tuvieron un entorno
social para practicar la empatía y la
tolerancia con sus compañeros y frente a
las autoridades los expertos señalan que
hay más razones tras este explosivo
Retorno a las clases en Chile en 2022
conversamos de esto con Vania Martínez
psiquiatra y experta en Salud Mental de
jóvenes y adolescentes sobre el
incremento de la deserción y la
violencia escolar que se vive en el país
cómo interpretas tú estas cifras de
deserción y los actos de violencia
escolar que han ocurrido en Chile Cómo
se pueden explicar Sí yo creo que hay
que separar los temas uno es deserción
escolar y en ese caso es importante los
datos que se han mencionado es de
preocupación porque sabemos que el
colegio y en general los
establecimientos escolares pueden ser un
factor de protección pero también podría
ser factores de riesgo Entonces el hecho
de que haya una deserción escolar uno
podría pensar qué ocurrió quizás hay
bullying ciberbullying de por medio
quizás hay problemas de aprendizaje
quizás la familia les ha costado
mantener a sus hijos en los
establecimientos escolares tal vez por
razones económicas tal vez también no
tienen como
cuidarlos o trasladarlos durante la
pandemia vimos como en muchas ocasiones
tuvieron que acompañar a sus hijos en
clases en línea y pudiera ser que eso
también dificultó el aprendizaje ya
entonces hay varios factores que podrían
estar en juego en la deserción escolar
si bien los datos muestran que la
deserción es un fenómeno común América
Latina sí que el incremento
significativo de los actos de violencia
que la superintendencia fija en un 50%
más que con respecto al año pasado sí
que son algo más particular de chile qué
está pasando ahí qué es lo que estaría
operando más allá de todas las efectos
de la pandemia chile sí le ha tocado
varios aspectos uno fue el estallido
social sabemos que con el estallido
social o hartos cambios movilizaciones y
después de eso la pandemia que es otro
fenómeno además en este momento hay
harta incertidumbre económica política
en términos de seguridad en nuestro país
que puede ponerlo en una posición
diferente a otro países de la creatina
sin embargo coincidimos en algunos
elementos como son los problemas de
salud mental que efectivamente se ha
visto un incremento en la población de
adolescentes y jóvenes a nivel mundial
nosotros en chile y especialmente
depresión y ansiedad el estallido social
de 2019 que desató una ola de violencia
normalizada como forma de protesta
Podría tener también un impacto en lo
que está sucediendo en el país donde
también se experimenta al igual que en
el aula más violencia en las calles las
cifras difundidas recientemente por la
policía en Chile son abrumadoras en el
2022 65.000 niños pasaron por las
comisarías del país 15.000 de ellos por
cometer delitos el resto por ver
vulnerados sus derechos En total son más
de 200 niños niñas y adolescentes los
que pasan por una comisaría cada día el
aumento de la violencia pone una alta
presión en el gobierno de Gabriel boric
para atender el tema del trato a la
niñez y a la adolescencia que viene
Arrastrando la sociedad y el estado
chileno y que ha explotado en el último
año con nuevas complejidades
hasta aquí nuestro programa de hoy
Seguiremos informando en nuevas
ediciones de enlace cono Sur